yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a new part of the chess openings
Q&A and there's so many questions some
I'm not going to be able to answer them
all in that video but I definitely want
to record one and answer a couple of
them in particular the ones that don't
require you have some longish
explorations on my part some of the
questions I can answer quite um yeah
quite easily because it's just what I
have no anyway I don't need to do any
work on that so let's start with one
that is a bit older and this is about
the English defense on the black side
this is the English defence and that is
actually quite okay opening for black
against deform it is a bit risky but
it's not terrible and I've played it
myself
with black quite a bit mostly in games
where I wanted to unbalance the whole
issue a little bit and the answer is
sorry the question if I but Douglas here
is what is the best line against this
what is the most testing line that is
quite easy to answer and it's definitely
e-form
and after that you don't have an easy
time on a statement after Bishop b7 the
move that is critical is Bishop d3 I
don't seem 93 being too threatening
there are also some ideas there for
white but I don't think this is the main
problem Bishop d3 years and gets the
most testing line the problem is that
the aggressive approach with f5 doesn't
quite work because white can take this
is I know it's not totally clear cut
it's a bit of a work to check out but
it's stiff it is difficult for black to
play very risky and the problem is that
the non f5 lions are also not that great
some players went 96 attacking him and
then played night before but this is at
the end a big center for wide that you
don't attack this has been um a move
that has been tried a lot but here white
has an accident replied King f1 this is
however not very well known so this is
something that you can definitely try to
make work yeah King f1 basically tells
black ok no bishop that doesn't do
anything and you probably have to move
it again so this is I think what is the
most testing line the most aggressive
line and that is what I would recommend
to white players to play against the
other part of the question here but like
this was what should he do against an
early a3 should he go for Queens gambit
declined structure so play some sort of
d5 this is possible probably that were
transposed to a more Queen's Indian type
of game with 90 f6 and d5 but against a3
I don't see anything wrong with ya
getting some f5 based setup plate this
is one of the and that say reasons why
he would blame the development of the
noid I think this line with the d5 is
probably slightly better for white but
it's very complicated and definitely a
playable option in general um playing
those kind of those openings that are
somewhat ignorant of the center I mean
you allow this and there are reasons why
if you look at the very top level you'll
rarely see white getting those free
pawns in the center they all play like
d4 d5 or d4 Knight f6 stop that there
are reasons why the top guys don't
really risk that and if you play this
kind of stuff with black you should
really put some study time in and ya
work something out like if you play this
and somebody who really is knowledgeable
plays king of one you shouldn't start to
think but have something so idea
it's not like you're lost I do you think
but it's just like this is super
annoying if it happens and you have no
clue what to do there's a quite unknown
game by and women's world champion Joe
when Joe and I think she is the current
four champion again right with white
against Nigel short when I really got
totally kills with black so and this is
about the English defense so go to the
next one the next one is what about the
vert the fence in the room is this
playable on an 1,800 level yeah of
course yeah and this is this line is
it's not fantastic we have to be honest
there it's not a fantastic opening line
but it is a playable line you're not
going to lose by force or anything and
you sometimes see reasonably strong
players play that as a surprise weapon
so um white will take and now you can
castle or you can play Bishop c4 but
with Musa I think very much relevant and
it is a playable line I think it is
quite risky and I'm not really sure I'm
not so sure about the incentive because
you rarely get something great out of it
I've looked at this actually with black
because I mean it's something that no
white player ever study so I think you
can make a make and make a point that no
white player will know stuff but I am
not quite sure what a good really good
outcome for black looks like in this
line so I'm not a huge fan of this line
with black but if he was somehow I feel
attracted to it and invest a bit of time
you can definitely play it would I play
it against a strong player that is
prepared no I wouldn't but if you have
playing in your local club competition
and want to surprise somebody why not
however if it comes to surprises you can
do many things against
against the way that nobody probably
will know and I'm not so sure if I would
really go with the bird for example
let's say let's say you study the the
Sriman or Danish gambit said two
different lines and this is something
where you can really get to get an
advantage with black if they play
something weird yeah if they don't know
what they're doing or you can do
something of British that is not so
committal yeah for example I recently
saw game the Magnussen rapid game play
Bishop before that looks working and
it's not fantastic but I think it's less
of a commercial decision like the bird
is but if you like it I think with some
study time you can definitely make it
work on the 1,800 level absolutely okay
the next question is a very general one
about my motivation behind switching
openings over the years you know of
course I've switched quite a bit over
the years and it is a very broad
question that I don't know how how much
of a storytelling video I want to make
out of this the main reasons why I
switched openings over the years the
main reason is actually simply the
desire to study something you see
something different
explore new things nowadays okay I'm
still next to Flair but nowadays my my
curiosity is basically satisfied by
starting new opening projects like
writing new books and videos for
chasuble whatever and all this is done
to satisfy my simply my curiosity when
what what you got what what is playable
what is interesting and so on so I
didn't have that many reasons over the
years to discard an opening you to
school the only thing that I really
discarded you to scorn is the French I
played it a lot and I scored really
really badly
that was around 2004 2005 when I simply
got fed up with that I really I lost too
many games and in fact I think I already
stopped this too late I shoulda stopped
that earlier and back then when I when I
when when I saw okay I should have been
done the French I turned to with black
for the first time studying a 45 I never
did that and I'm still playing this as
my main response but I'm mixing it with
all kinds of openings
even the French once in a while I really
had a bad experience with this opening
but it is not because it is bad or
anything that's not the case it's just
like it's not that not everybody can
play everything you need to really
develop a feel for things and I over the
years have found that I am simply have
problems with black in structures that
are very typical of the French with e5
I'm not saying the advanced variation
particularly just the structure that I
struggle with this lack of space on the
kingside it's just that I have problems
I don't have a good feel for when you
should play of six and so on so it's
more like me not being able to play it
well I also wouldn't play let's say the
King's gambit well yeah it's just like
it's not my kind of game and that is
what I recognized so for me stopping
white from advance in d5 my ways of
doing that is to play in five myself so
I'm not in a space disadvantage but I
have switched away from many openings
over the years not to to score simply
because I wanted to learn something new
for example I always had good scores
with black in the King's Indian I played
that in the 1990s my score was excellent
really I had no reason to ever abandon
the opening I also had good scores with
black in in the Slav they played that
later but it's so switched away simply
because I learn
new things and I wanted to explore
something of something else
my main recommendation always is to
against with black in particular against
the main opening z4 in default you
should have one line one complex one
opening that you know well as well as
possible as your time permits and make
that a main main defense that you can
always use if you don't know anything
better or have no particular idea for
again then stick to what you know best
and then you can always branch out from
that that is what my recommendation is
that is what I am basically doing for
example I applied a 45 if you just like
wake me up in the middle of the night
I'm going to play that and then play
some away whatever but in a particular
game I might play anything because I
think for that game why not why not risk
it depends on the opponent and so on but
you should know something well it is not
such a great thing to know five openings
on a mediocre level I think it's better
to know one thing well and then
occasionally you have set some surprise
that also will lead you to lead you to
explore new things and to have some
sometimes you need a little bit of spark
yeah if you do the same thing and the
episode is same thing every single game
I think that makes you it's just not so
interesting but don't do do the
switcheroo all the time yeah you should
know something really well
okay okay all those here covered
yeah and that's a good question here by
I'm not done yet as a bad to say it's an
interesting question and it's by
Deauville proof where did you choose the
Rosslyn limo at mass Moscow variation
form I keep it simple repertoire and not
the regular other pin which would have
been even simpler yeah that's true I
chose to play the LP against musics but
against d6 Bishop b5 and against 96 I
also went to should be 5 why why did I
not recommend to c3 there are a couple
of reasons I'm sorry there are a couple
of reasons
first of all there's one very basic
reason and that is subjective strength
it's just a draw so limo and Moscow I
think are setting more problems for
black than the other P where black
basically yeah I mean it depends on what
kind of level we're talking yeah
the rosolie modem and and Moscow they
are completely valid main lines up to
Magnus up to the highest possible level
well nobody plays III because black can
basically equalize with a couple of
lines then it's not so relevant on the
amateur level I'm totally aware of that
so I could have gone for c3 and it's
totally fine however I thought that if
you incorporate those lines you actually
have a little bit more variety because
if you play C 3 you will get the same
kind of porn structures every single
game you will get IQ p positions a lot
and positions that give you if you go C
3 you will get those positions are not
where you get the IQ p or you will get
this particular structure a lot and of
course you can get that from the e6 type
variation that I'm recommending as well
but that's just a small percentage while
if you play the Rosso Nemo and learn
that
and for example they play and the most
popular move g6 I had to recommend to
castle but now from here you have the
choice later to expand into a multiple
like a huge variety of positions you can
you can take you can play c3 d4 there
are all kinds of things like you cancel
like here I recommend to do this for
example and then play 93 but you can
also play c3 in this position or you can
play c3 here and they need two totally
different structures so I felt that if
you learn the roster limo for example
same applies for the Moscow but a little
bit less it's a it's a better investment
let's say for the future that was what
my consideration was you can more easily
expand from that now and this is the
main motivation plus them a little bit
it's about the quality I think the
roster demo sets more problems nc3 which
does not say you shouldn't place in 3 if
you like it it's totally ok also on move
to but I felt this is more but it's
something that people can use for a
longer time with more flexibility and
also honestly it's also sometimes what I
want to investigate myself because I
think about what I play myself what I
recommend it to students and so on and
Bishop b5 is just a great a great way of
playing against the Sicilian ok um the
next question
it's a really no one okay let me after
recalling and what it is
okay so it's a really long long text and
I do agree to some sort
it's about gambit lines and we're
talking about gambit lines like this
yeah where the author says that he
enjoys playing them from time to time
because it leads to energetic gambit
play something like this I assume and
maybe some f3 yeah well you can probably
guess that I don't think it's a good
idea to play that all too often because
in many of those lines I really don't
see any any compensation at all but I
mean it's your only responsibility yeah
but what you want to play especially if
it is not the most important game ever
do it yeah if you play those gambits and
you are playing in the same team as I am
yeah I'm going to I'm going to have a
few honest ones what's with you that
that's not a good idea to play if you're
in a team competition I really don't
think that's a bet so great but if you
want to experiment of course why not
this for example looks odd if you ask me
I mean where exactly it's a compensation
I will even do this next
the main issue by the way with this f3
stuff is often that just weakens or not
it's not just that the pawn is a problem
okay so yeah that's a good question
by TG wnn what to do against the other
pain the see through selling with black
and what to play if you don't want to
play she don't want to fall asleep yeah
he mentioned that d6 was played by
Magnus Carlsen in a band to blitz sure I
mean that is a playable move of course
it is not the best possible line maybe
but it's definitely not going to lose
for
you like the the problem but this is a
little bit that if if white is something
enterprising like taking it can be
interesting but if they play something
normal like develop I feel that those
positions are sometimes a little bit
one-sided or a little bit boring it's a
you don't really get the goal of a
complicating matters it is difficult to
complicate matters I have some general
recommendations against our opinion for
example I like many d5 lines because in
my personal experience if you want to
win it is often not a bad thing to get a
structured in balance and here quite
often right forget the iqp which at
least you know what to play against and
there is some again some imbalance in
play I think in fact there are quite a
number of lines that are satisfactory
here and it's a matter of taste what to
choose
you have to check out ever what you play
here because in some cases let's say you
play six for whatever the time on/off or
so and they play C free then you are
seriously limited of course and it is a
little bit useless to learn two
different lines for 2 C 3 and 3 C 3 most
of it is a matter of taste I personally
like the 5 lines more than 9 of 6 but
this is more of a general general thing
or more of a taste to think that say
it's not an objective value in those
lines if you want to unbalanced I think
it's not a bad idea to look into stuff
that is related to this structure here
with d6 you can sometimes put the bishop
here Knight to d7 this I don't think is
very draw much honestly but it's
possible that white is not better but
it's something you give white a little
bit more than it usually gets but in
return it is like a non symmetrical and
more of
position so then it's also a thing to
play what I personally play is this but
again there are many nights I've
switched I've switched around a lot if
you just if you just want to make a draw
you can play that where white has
basically nothing this is one of the
reasons why serious in my opinion yeah I
mean if you want to draw against you
three you can do that and you go home
basically um I mean white has like this
this minimal of an advantage if he plays
15 moves of theory and nobody does that
so alright and this is not what you
wanted yeah you wanted to fight but this
is something where you can kill off the
game if you want I had this in the
Bundesliga in the second league once we
had exactly this game and basically draw
a grid against the 2500 player who also
didn't know that line and you won't find
much for white I'm sure maybe this
little but it's not alone okay
the next one at Liam at Liam no asked
any recommendations for winning chances
as black against the exchange Slav yeah
these are the the good ones here with
black against the exchanged love you
know it's difficult obviously my main
advice is honestly you have to have the
right attitude if you play against a
good opponent like your rating or
something around your rating
you know you play a game if it's a draw
it's fine yeah if you are an absolute
must win situation like you have to win
it or costs I'm not sure that I would
play d4 d5 c4 c6 I mean you can do it it
has been done by players but I don't
think in a must-win that is the best
possible approach if you just have like
I ran
game when you're the better player and
they play the exchange and you want to
win my main advice is to just be totally
aware that the game will last for a
while and you have to simply grind it
out it will take a long time and I
honestly I've never lost with black in
the exchange laughs and I've won a
couple of games have won a huge
percentage effect against slightly
weaker players and most in those games
took like 70 moves but at the end you're
often prevail and in terms of what would
you what should you play you can try a
couple of things to unsettle white yeah
for example if they start with this move
you could it's a little bit risky but
you could actually look at E 5 I think
that would irritate many people and then
move this not terrible it's about about
this it can be quite a shock on this is
better than it looks maybe at first you
think okay what is that you know what is
black doing well it is not so bad this
is an interesting line you can also
investigate ideas with the quick Queen
to b6 if they develop the queenside
early on which is not bad for white but
here for example if white wants to play
for something he has to play III yeah
III is the best move and then you can
think about snatching the pawn attract
moment which will sharpen things up
people who are ever playing for draw who
just want a draw
they will probably play something that
will help you a little bit we are like a
queen t2 or so and it's not terrible but
it's not really testing for black
whatever you do you will never get
something fantastic yeah it's just like
it's such a solid line and what I think
is interesting if you plan for win want
to play for win is to actually think
about playing something that looks a
little bit passive at first which is a
bit counterintuitive but do something
like with these six when you keep many
pieces on the board there should be
seven castles and just keep this I know
it looks it looks bad but it's tough to
use
tough to really exploit as wide and just
yeah try to keep as many pieces on as
possible I personally have played a six
or Maya or the or all over the years
when I played the Slav and then most of
the time I got this out and traded it
off and then try to win some ending
which most of the time worked but it
takes 80 moves but that is just what it
is there's no way out of that you cannot
really set the board on fire in the in
the Slav exchange an interesting way of
playing by the way if they play this
particular move order is Knight e4
Knight h5 but if wise knows the stuff
it's still going to be a dry symmetrical
game that is just the nature of the
position okay the next question yeah
this is a bit general here by in a Gila
if I cooked over some openings lines
which lead to good end games for both
white and black yeah if there would be
something like that the core world class
would would play it here however you can
of course if you want to go for endings
if you like endings you can of course
adjust your opening repertoire a little
bit to go for more endings than you
probably are say let's say the
percentage of openings leading to
endings differs from opening to open it
a little bit yeah there are some that
are somewhat more endgame heavy maybe
and mainly if you enjoy endings is for
me not a bad idea to focus on openings
that lead to healthy porn structures
which is often a key a key thing for
example I'm giving you one if you let's
say you'll write them and
you play you play like this and it is
probably not the best idea if you have
anything in mind it's probably not the
best idea to play the same ish in the
noobs Oh like and your whole queenside
is bad it's weakened
and why does basically going
strategically speaking all-in on move
for a white wants to play a big center
attack oops sorry
attack on the kingside I fled some
interesting blitz games with this over
the years on the white side and it led
to many attacking wins but you also
suffer in any ending like if your widget
ending here you really have to yeah
connected some other pluses on the way
because the Queen side is is toasters
toast so you can oppose look for lines
that are less of this start where you
don't have long-term strategic
weaknesses yeah very end game heavy
opening for example it's the Catalan it
can get sharp but there are many lines
if we for example get the total main
line here the city takes we now know
that looks like a deep line but it's
something that you get on the board here
for example there are many lines that
are extremely endgame heavy and that can
be played yeah pretty much without not a
lot of deep theoretical knowledge there
are many trades it's very it is rather
dry there are some some players who have
a very end game heavy style for example
a classic example is wolf under zone
from the top player in the 1980s and 90s
mostly wolf um yeah had many openings in
his repertoire that would lead to a very
strategic position that are very endgame
heavy if you want to look at another
player with some very endgame oriented
player it's not so well known and not
i rated as of us is Keith Arc of
Grandmaster Arco from from the UK he's a
great end game player and he has a solo
repertoire set towards yeah getting
those little nibbles and just tried to
win it the ending it's not a bad idea to
get inspiration from players who have a
very strategic style and then see what
lines are they playing okay
the next question that SW came is that
in my keep it simple repertoire there is
a common theme that white is playing for
pawn store in the kingside in many
nights and this is true for example I'm
going to put something on the broad and
he's referring to lines like this where
let's say it doesn't really like
tirikatene
when I'm recommending to play this and
this there there are also similar lines
where the bishop is here and he asks
basically why doesn't why develop his
LightSquared Bishop before he starts
pushing the pawns
it seems contrary to traditional wisdom
of developing all your pieces before
attacking yeah I see what you're what
you add but the thing is that the bishop
or f1 does not really need a different
square it is no we're really in a better
position the only reason why you would
maybe move it is that you would connect
rooks other than that it's very rarely
seen that this Bishop has asked where to
go to in the English attack in the in
the in the Sicilian the bishop is also
quite often just simply staying on f1
you want to save the time associated
with moving it and often the the way in
the game develops later points to root
square yeah you're only know where it is
useful later
for example in the Sicilian you
sometimes see cases if we put the
Sicilian on the board
I don't really am if somebody knows this
very well he would probably point out
that I'm not playing in the most precise
move water or something I'm just I just
want to make a point about the position
of type let's say you have oftentimes
stuff like this where white is pushing
under on the kingside and here for
example sometimes putting the bishop
here can make sense because that is a
target I see that here Knight c4 has a
thing much like here it is just more
important to get the pawns rolling then
put a bishop or to eat or something yeah
it's just more important and often later
according to the the way the game
progressed then you know better where to
put the bishop so this is actually
rather common that the bishop is not
moving in those attacking formations and
the next question is that keep it simple
d 4s coming in in male 8 a.m. and it
teases we can look forward to I don't
really want to talk too much about about
any details I have the lion slide out
basically I know what I'm going to
recommend some some for some openings
the whole thing is almost completed for
some it's not I know what to do what
they don't have detail this is I'm very
happy in running I have to say with with
what I'm having so far and I'm really
looking forward to play these these
things if myself I'm not doing that at
the moment really I don't have any
tournaments coming and and I also don't
want to yea hint too much I mean it is
some something maybe we'll have to wait
in a couple of weeks though ok thanks
for the question ok the next one
yep
yeah there's a question if it is an idea
for black to play against deform it's a
question by luxury literature and if it
is an idea for black against d4 to
transpose into the st. George defense
with b5e for a six
he says the replies most afraid of is
3c4 okay well in 6b five it has been
famously played by Tony miles winning
against cup off in 1980 or 1981 1980s
long time ago and it is one of those
openings that well it cannot be great
but it's also not so terrible that you
need to lose immediately can you play
that yes
should you play that probably no I don't
really see a huge incentive of doing it
is it really so bad playing against d4
that you want to play b5 I don't know I
feel if it's a bit it's a bit much
giving white an advantage so early on
okay I don't think c4 is I mean it's a
plane will move I usually just recommend
to develop with Bishop f3 vision idea 3
Bishop d3 a kind of normal setup
basically what Karpov also played in
that game I think that's what I
recommended it keep it simple a4 and
it'll probably being keep it simple d4
as well yeah and the d4 d5 I really
think efore is the way to go yeah this
is just not yeah not a great opening
it's you know you won't lose like
immediately all the time but I really
questioned why you would want to play
him that is quite clearly not so great
so early on if you want to play non
theoretical let's say I do understand
that might be your motivation then I
think there are probably some other
options that are a little bit less
questionable for example some g6 based
lines or you just say the second one I
can answer quite quite clearly as a
weapon for black what is my opinion
about the following variation g 6d for
Bishop g7 my opinion is you shouldn't
play it it's just very clear opinion
I mean you can probably play it and
people won't refute it every every
single game but if you meet somebody who
really wants to notice that you play
that and he wants to kill you and he
knows how to use the database or books
or something then he will find a way
because this ad takes e5 is just
terrible for like just what it is you
won't get a decent position anymore yeah
you can play this c3 Queen takes 93 and
this is not it's not possible to
equalise anymore and you will very
likely get into trouble I mean you have
to I mean work really really hard to get
a playable position from that this is
just one problem
again c4 you're in some weird fianchetto
system or you have to transpose it to my
Roxy also not great or they can go into
benoni which is also better for white
and so on I mean like everything is
better for white and I don't see why you
would want to do it simply I know it is
it's in a book the sniper but that book
is terrible and the opening is just look
which is bad I mean I really wouldn't do
it okay so yeah this I've done this yeah
the next one is a little bit is it a
little bit general the best lines to
play with black against the Squatch yeah
the Scotch is also a wide range sure
there is just got four nights regular
one I know it's a very general question
I still think I mean I have this line
that I've done a video on a long time
ago with bishop before check I think for
a less vertical line it's completely
okay so I don't really see a big issue
and everything is OK Bishop c5 and 9 f6
are both ok they do require some study
though and it's not like so so easily
done I think if you ask the the top
players there
probably say Knight f6 is best but this
is not so relevant for any other level
than the then the absolute highest I
think black is okay if you know what to
do if you want an offbeat line
I think Bishop before check is still
okay my video is a bit of wood but
nothing fundamental I think has has
changed with a little bit of work you
can make it in line they can play
regularly the next question buyback pipe
is setting is interested in in the
Queens gambit accepted and he would like
some resources about that and then there
was an answer that some Collins has a
nice DVD on that and I don't have that
but the repertoire choices that he has
made according it to the text sound
interesting they you know that I think
the qgn is a quite quite good opening
and it is quite possible that I'm going
to produce something on it as well so
maybe you just need to be a bit patient
if you are interested in what I'm
analyzing at some point there is also
book by I think by Dell chef that is
quite reasonable that I also have
somewhere here in this in this maze maze
of shelves um okay so the next thing is
so so much questions and how does the
video forty minutes okay not like some
more and next question the verdict on
the Grand Prix attack for white which
side is it good for and wild explanation
was showing some lines is it
recommendable and to which level of
players the chrome Prix is the following
I assume yeah 93 first okay so 93 first
and then f1
I think it is it is not a better break
line you can definitely play it for
blackness I think quite quite simple to
determine what what what what best is
and first of all if black can play this
I mean if you place a knight of
regularly this move is a bit tricky
because you could be mu ordered but
let's say black places yeah just for
argument's sake a form and now black
most of the time Plains g6 I think this
is the critical line and we get here now
I think that why it should definitely go
Bishop b5 and not Bishop c4 I don't
think you mentioned any preference there
yeah I think why should definitely play
Bishop b5 against Bishop c4 e6 9075
I think is quite okay for black I would
compare should be five and now I think
what is interesting
definitely for widest said any moves
other than 94 is just not good I mean if
they play is some non movement you can
take on c6 play b3 this is very
comfortable so 94 and then let's say
castling and those lines are interesting
definitely and I don't think that black
players will be all that knowledgeable
it's a sight line and it's a bit it's
it's a bit of a non priority for black
players they often focus on their main
line their dragon there whatever they
play and don't really look at this all
that much for black I would definitely
recommend to play like that that is by
far the best line and for white you
should of course study all the lines to
some degree but focus on on this complex
if you study this well and be and you
are knowledgeable and I think it's a
it's a playable line of course I think
this should be a focus you know look at
look at this and of course again it's
good
know how to punish the bad line save it
if you can let's say yeah make this work
for you then you have a really
interesting weapon on your hands I
wanted to mention that just to maybe
Arabia was too quick there from the
black point of view if you decide you're
on a move you need to be aware that 93
does not mean for sure that they play
close Sicilian or pre they can still
play neither 392 next and play d4 that
means if you're angling for a night off
as black for example and you play this
and now white goes here and now you
don't get a night off anymore I mean
unless you play e5 then we'll play d4
next and then you have something else
for example I don't know you can get an
accelerated dragon or something but no
night off so 93 and 4/9 of players is a
bit of a nuisance often they play d6 or
a six which kind of fits into the night
off and there is also something
different than definitely form for white
so I don't think the groom Prius is
terrible you can definitely play it it's
not something that I do recommend
usually to players but if they already
do it their score is fine it's not so
bad that you have to give it up um okay
you
I am yeah that's a good good question
there and the question is about lines
like this before
c6 d for g6 now okay just a bit of an
odd move order okay Vanessa for which
could be an issue but okay g6 93 d5 if
this line is playable yeah it's
definitely playable am a huge fan
probably not but it's it is a playable
line you have to think about the move
water a little bit if that is a really
good move order most players angling for
that they do it like this somehow and
then d5 I understand that you lousy
forward it's kind of unavoidable it's
really unavoidable or you can start with
the karo and then play g6 in any case it
is definitely playable what I am however
think I just want to make a couple of
some pointers if Y planes be five I am
fairly sure you should not play an h5
but it's setup but rather something with
f6 and that h6 yeah what I'm talking
about is there is stuff like that and I
think h5 is just not a good but I don't
like that line it's so passive I would
rather go a night h6 f6 and try to
attack the center that I think has a
somewhat reasonable reputation in my
efore repertoire
I recommended for y2 this line and I
think that white gives a small advantage
there but it's not like you cannot play
it so I think it's it's okay to do it
with black I mean it's slightly better
for white but it's not that white can
blow you over the board
and the next question is the Monocacy
binders right can you avoid the Sicilian
main lines and play c4 on move 3 or 2
transpose it into a standard peroxy bite
what is the drawback the drawback is
that him black can play 96 stop your
deform and if you now want to insist on
that
for example with 93 or 92 when it's a
usual 9 f3
then black has a couple of interesting
options the most interesting one a
notion and I'm sure it's the most
interesting one it is the most
principled one of you in any case is
simply gonna be 5 and in this position
you have committed your night to a
less-than-ideal square because here you
often rather want it on e 2 because G 3
F 4 is a later idea of course you can go
night e 2 but that is not very
threatening a different idea for black
even after this by the way is to play
something like this which is also
completely fine for black the main
reason however is that quickie 5 simply
blocking everything yeah if they would
play g6 you can get into a Roxy that
would work but black will probably stop
it with a line like the one I just
mentioned there are also other wacky
ideas I mean they've even tried this
since it's the way but ok it's not
really a big reason
[Music]
you
okay the next one I cannot
the answer it's a bit too so the too
complicated yeah I think and there's too
many there's too many I think I should
stop now making this video longer than
40-something minutes is a bit much so
I'm going to stop and end the video here
think we've gotten in quite a number of
things and I'm going to make more of
these of course but it's sometimes not
so easy to get everything answered yeah
I hope you enjoyed it until next time
bye bye